[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm Brett and I'm Linc this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are going
to dive deep into some conflict and you
know what
then we're gonna we're gonna surface
with resolutions and it's not conflict
between the two of us and though that
may happen red it could over the court
anything goes when we have asked you
loyal ear biscuit ear listeners and
other mythical beasts on social media to
let us know about disagreements that you
have with a friend roommate sibling a
loved one significant other us
indefinitely that and we're not just
gonna be answering these questions we're
not gonna just be reading these
questions we're gonna do something that
we've talked about doing for a long time
we've never actually done it we're gonna
try it tonight
uh-huh we're gonna take calls see how
that is now the way we did this just in
case you met Larry King yeah he was on
hiatus and you know he did that for for
millennium but before we before we met
Larry King we wanted to do this now just
a technical clarification before you
start being like what's the number well
hey this isn't live you already know
that you're a thoughtful person be what
we did is we took your questions on the
internet and then we reached out
directly to a handful of people and
those people will be calling it so
that's how it works yeah it's just more
you know if you're gonna if you're gonna
help somebody solve a problem I want
them I want them to say yes you did it
and then we can say good luck with that
yeah yeah and that but we can feel like
Ewing feel like they're that they're
gonna take our advice the thing is that
just put it out into the ether and maybe
that maybe it's helping maybe it's not I
got I gotta say I'm I got some
reservations about this because I don't
feel like we're qualified counselors I
don't feel like we're really we're
making it interpersonal we're like
really bringing them into the convo we
may give someone advice this week that
ends a relationship I mean think about
that this is this is the potential that
we hold right now well the end of a
relationship is the potential for the
beginning of another
that's always true Sedna said that now I
should have said that at the end of like
if something was really going south any
I don't you know I'm kind of I'm ready
to get into it so let's let's uh let's
take our first call let's get into some
conflicts oh gosh nervous hello welcome
to ear biscuits who do we have here
how's it going it's going good is that
your name how's it going is that all one
word no hello Shannon Shannon welcome to
the show now you are having some sort of
conflict that we might be able to help
with what is it we are actually um well
we've been having this discussion
who's we Candice hmm who is we I'm her
husband Zach oh yeah we've been having a
debate let's say for about ten years
oh well and we need some help okay yeah
so the debate is okay according to
international standards Monday is the
first day of the week so when I said so
when I say next week I mean starting on
Monday but that is absolutely firm in
his belief that the Week starts on
Sunday so we're we have this debate on
which day the week starts Sunday or
Monday Monday and I'm definitely team
Monday and hmm how long have you been at
this debate ten years I said honestly
well no actually it's longer than that
because it was probably in 98 it started
that would be 20 years yeah 21 years hey
great a good answer Zach that's good and
where are you guys located whether or
not in the same place right now because
they can't stand to be around each other
I'm just trying to have all this all the
facts here
yeah where in the world are you we're in
Novi Michigan know by Michigan okay
okay so it's Michigan now in novi I just
want are there you still have seven days
right I mean it's just I just want to
make sure yeah Tuesday Tuesday Wednesday
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
okay that was an interesting way I don't
know if that's a tell as a how you're
gonna answer this question because you
just started your week on Tuesday I
didn't I didn't want to give either of
them how intense is this debate gotten
between the two of you you seem pretty
jovial at the moment are you putting on
your best behavior for your biscuits
there well sure I mean we've gotten
intense with the discussion to the point
of like you know having problems with
scheduling oh so it's wrong it's ruined
plans like you're saying you know I'll
we'll do it next week and then it's you
know for Zach that means tomorrow
oh that week yeah
hey we you know we have plans next week
why he really means is this weekend
mm-hmm for example if it's day if it's
say if it's Thursday and we've got plans
for three days from now I'll say let me
call that we have plans for next weekend
because that is the next time it is a
weekend no but they're her next weekend
being skip weekend
and then the following Halloween weekend
it's like phantom weekend no hmm yeah
this is trouble this is this is
troubling me just hearing you begin to
argue about it again okay okay because I
I think I think I have my answer but is
it but before before I give it I want to
make sure I want to I want to give
everyone their their fair shake you said
Shannon according to international
standards of the week starts on Monday
yeah well I don't know what what what
are international standards are you
referring to there's literally
international standards committees there
is
I looked it up Wikipedia you know so
that means it's true okay
where are they where these committees
located and who do they consist of I'm
not sure you think she's reading the
Wikipedia footnotes no she finds what
she wants the answer she wants and then
she's like here it is she's not digging
deeper if it's what no no but I say it's
generally noted by people like if you
went out to the street and you asked
someone they would probably say the
beginning of the week is Monday I doubt
that they would say Sunday because
people you know they start their work
weekend Monday - they have to consider
that right I think there's a couple of
things cut there's a couple of things
complicating this so just to lay it lay
them out here so yes I would agree with
you Shannon that generally speaking our
work week starts on a Monday and I think
that the situation that Zak outlined in
which he was talking and then something
was happening on this coming Sunday and
he says next weekend now we are in this
is a confusing place right if he would
have said next week that would be
consistent with his position that the
next week starts on Sunday however if he
said next weekend there are there are
two things that are just from a
technical perspective I will say our
ends acts favor just just to lay it out
there number one if the week doesn't
begin on a Sunday and in most calendars
especially American calendars they go
from Sunday to Saturday right so the the
if you just look at a grid on a calendar
typically they start on a Sunday so it
may not be according to international
standards but American calendars and you
are both in America because last time I
checked Michigan is within the American
borders then what would that would lead
me to believe is that Zack considers
Sunday and Saturday to be week ends
meaning as if they were book ends so if
I have a collection of books and I
put them up on the shelf and I put a
book in on each end of those books then
that is the weekend according to Zach
well let's ask him is that what you're
saying yeah because I did not even get
that since you're agreeing with me I'm
gonna totally go along with it
and I have one more thought which i
think is a lock well hold on so so so
you're I'm not saying I agree with you
Zach I'm just trying to articulate your
argument so that we can all be on the
same page so you're commandeering
Rhett's argument because it benefits you
but it only wasn't your argument only
makes sense if you see it that way so
the fact that you're now just taking it
makes me makes me can begin to doubt
your foot sunday is the first week end
and then of the same week the other end
of that week is Saturday so those are
the two week ends I've never thought of
it that well and so in that book and
that's an instance two weeks have four
weekends which nobody actually thinks
that Zach but but you know what that's
cool it's a cool thought it's a cool way
to think about it in theory but in
practice I guess it's getting you into
trouble but again he's not that's not
what he was thinking he's saying well
now that you explained it that way I'm
gonna start bright exactly describing it
that way yes and Jacob has just just to
confirm what Shannon said Jacob has just
brought this up according to
international standard that's the ISO
International Organization for
Standardization that's a standard as it
gets eight 601 Monday is the first day
of the week it is followed by Tuesday
well but why don't calendars say that I
think that's the problem here yeah it is
what has led to the confusion is that
the calendar does not represent this but
I think that most people when they say
this weekend they're talking about
Saturday and Sunday together and then I
know and that's that's again I think
that's that's leading us off the
argument which is not we're not talking
about whether what what the term this
weekend or next weekend means we're
talking about
here we are because that's the week leg
and Saturday and Sunday is the end of
that week which would mean that
day would be the beginning of said next
week and typically I mean I think most
people conceptually when you look at the
packet you got I I feel like you've got
two packets when you look at a week
you've got Monday through Friday which
we call the weekdays and then we've got
the weekend those are two separate
packets they're not three packets as
Zach would have lead you to believe it's
two packets of information in a weekend
I I have found it psychologically
beneficial to think of a weekend me and
by that I mean a unit of a Saturday and
a Sunday that are back-to-back correct
is one weekend right I tend to think of
them as two separate entities one the
end of the week and the other Sunday the
beginning of the next week because Oh
what yeah you're on Zack side absolutely
but his argument that it is used is that
if if I told you you're doing something
on Sunday and I said next weekend would
you think I was talking about Sunday
would you would know but if he said next
week I would say okay Sunday is up for
grabs in that statement but here's why
but just practically speaking your life
will be better if you think of it this
way just because you know everybody
looks forward to their weekend
no matter what two days it happens to be
if you work a weird schedule but let's
just say it's Saturday and Sunday like
for most people I like to think that
Friday night and Saturday is just like
wrapping up a week and doing what I want
to do which really means doing what my
kids want to do now all right they
control us
but then Sunday you turn around and it's
like it's a fresh start that I still
have freedom that I don't have to I'm
not obligated about work even though I
love my work I still there's a joining
not being obligated to go into work I
mean it doesn't matter how great your
work is you're gonna feel that way well
that's how I feel
so sunday becomes the start of a new
week that still is just open and free
versus if you if you mentally think of
the beginning of your week as being
Monday that makes Monday's even worse
but if my birthday started 24 hours
early and I had I had free reign in the
place it's called
day my week has already started I'm 24
hours in I'm feeling good but if it's
all started on a Monday I start on a
real low point when you got to drag
yourself out of bed and go to work so
it's very helpful to for me to think of
it that way
psychologically but when communicated
mental and plus the calendar says that
you're on your own Shannon side okay yes
I am now but here but I think ultimately
without rehashing my argument which was
next week starts every week starts on a
Sunday I don't next week okay I don't
disagree with I'm not saying I
necessarily take issue with a week
starting on Sunday I take issue with
Zacks first argument which when he used
it in practice talking about next
weekend yeah I'm not with that so I
think here's here's what I'll say I your
whole booking thing is bunk it was
interesting it was fun exact didn't even
think that yeah until you said it but
what Zack said only makes sense only
makes sense it only makes sense from
your perspective if sudden okay are you
saying that Sunday isn't the weekend no
sunday is is like you said the book ends
I'll buy that because otherwise everyone
if there's a weekend and that's the end
of the week then people would call
Monday the week start if that was the
first day of the week doesn't make any
sense yeah so what I'm saying is
according to Zach and links position
that if you admit that the Week starts
on Sunday you're admitting that Saturday
and Sunday are not the same weekend you
cannot that is indisputable you cannot
say that that's not true you're saying
that no no it's a paradox oh it's a
paradox okay so if it is a paradox
because we haven't cleared anything up I
think that you guys have to adopt a
different system and that is why we have
dates you guys are going to have to use
definitive dates you're going to have to
say on June 8th like you can't you guys
have to drop the term week you have to
drop the term weekend but you can still
use days you can still say this Sunday
you can say next Sunday yes you could
you could say you could say days but I
think the foolproof way
is to communicate in numbers only and
maybe just certain to begin to
communicate in numbers exclusively in
all your relationship endeavors but just
I agree with that that is our advice but
I just want to clear up my position
which is that a weekend consists of the
end of one week in the beginning of
another one that is called a weekend
because they're both ends the ends come
together the end of the current week and
the beginning of the next week coming
together makes a weekend it's two butted
up against each other
it's the beginning no no it ends on a
Saturday and begins on a Sunday two
different weeks in they they they kiss
two weeks kiss on Saturday night at
midnight so in two weeks there's four
weekends according to you yeah and I
didn't even know that and so that
doesn't make any sense the application
of your argument breaks down that it
there they have week in a Saturday and a
Sunday are each different opposing ends
of different week you know what went
together they are a weekend we'll talk
about it this weekend how about that and
does that confuse you according to you
know it doesn't know this weekend is the
Saturday and Sunday together it is a
weekend okay Shannon and happens to be
two do you how do you guys feel about as
opposed to trying to come to terms
because I Lincoln I obviously can't what
do you think about is communicating with
dates I think that's a good plan I can
live with that okay good okay and you
everything's gonna be okay your marriage
will continue feels so good now alright
guys thanks for being our first ever
call into ear biscuits I you've created
problems in my own mind that I didn't
know existed
you created a weekend paradox you you
freaking it's contagious yeah good luck
with that
exactly yeah that is potentially the
upside of this thanks guys enjoy
Michigan it's gonna it'll get warm at
some point
you can say good luck with that cuz I
already said it okay good luck with that
alright we've got some more calls that
we are gonna take and based on how well
that one went boy my mind is blown you
talked yourself into a freakin paradise
man I don't know but I think again
that's why dates exist because of the
this type of confusion you know so we
don't even need to rehash it what we do
need to do is take a short break
and let you know that you can get these
boil for safety mugs that we're
currently drinking out of a short while
no more are gonna be made that's it so
get it while they're here cuz they won't
be when they're gone and that will be
soon and also I am using the mythical
pop socket now this is a you can use
this so you don't drop your phone hold
it right beside your face for um well
not like that hold it so they can see
the pop socket next you face for scale
there you go there you go you can still
talk why do they see that well it was
just on my phone you think this is like
a tablet I'm trying to give them the
single and my favorite use of the pop
socket is not just never dropping your
phone it's this like I want to show you
something that I'm gonna check that out
I love it when you do that okay I'll do
it more often
cuz I don't like you I don't like seeing
your hand behind your phone when I'm
watching something right cuz it could be
shaky and it's distracting just like
seeing a hand come off of a phone it's
distracting yeah you don't want that
also I mean while I'm plugging different
merch that you can get it mythical does
store I am wearing the rabbit lightning
t-shirt that has me and you on it that's
not us as characters who are not us nope
anyway there's lots of fun things
happening over mythical dot store
brighten your life up save your marriage
mythical dot store probably thank you
thank you for supporting internet
tainment let's get back into I want to
just go with another call yeah of course
yeah let's do it let's take our next
call to another one
I ran late
hello welcome to ear biscuits who do we
have here I'm Sam and Madison so it is
do you go by Maddy and do you go by
Samuel all right that's why they
introduced themselves as Madison okay I
respect that I just wanted to clarify
yeah okay where are you guys located
we're in Mississippi about 10 miles east
of Jackson okay well where are your
accents I know we we've only been here
for less than two years okay got it
give it time we're gonna get them yeah
you can't escape it okay and you guys
are married
yep and how long you been married
okay and what what are you arguing about
so we discovered this pretty soon after
we were first married but I think that
the original Oreo has the optimal creams
a cookie ratio okay and and Sam thinks
that Double Stuf Oreos improve on Oreo
and I think that they're worse this is a
big deal how how long have you been
argued about this or you two I guess
we've been married every time we get
Oreos which is how often twice a month
maybe oh oh wow you guys are really
Andorian y'all go through the bag Oreos
every two weeks and so what are your
problem what do you do when I shop I'm
just too impulsive and so I see them and
I just throw them in one okay all right
stop
I probably shut off about twice a month
this is probably that's more accurate
and so what I mean what do you did do
you alternate now what's the plan now so
usually we get a case of each or a taste
yeah you get in the case of Oreos
like a Costco how many you eat them for
meals but yeah okay okay well that
clouds the argument so we want we want
we won't even consider Chips Ahoy so
okay so right now Sam prefers the the
Double Stuf you prefer the original you
get separate boxes which is you know
that's that can be a little difficult on
the wallet now you're buying a lot of
Oreos right can you each just give your
can you just give your position for why
for why you think what you think right
well first of all it can I can I say
that I don't it's it's not technically
difficult on the wallet if you're if you
you know you buy twice as many but
you're it takes twice as long to eat
them yeah but they're not fresh Oreos
there's a this is why this is this is a
very important thing they don't sell a
pack that's half and half as far as I
know and Oreos change significantly 72
hours after opening
based on my experience is that is this
true based on your experience they get
mushy yeah they get mushy yet they
changed significantly I knew there was a
reason I didn't mean to worry us and so
I think that's why because you could
just say well who cares just buy
separate ones but I guess what I did say
but yeah okay the problem is the fresh
you got to go deeper then we got to go
deeper so if you could just outline your
argument for your position all right
well I think that the best part of the
Oreo is the chocolate cookie part and I
guess to to illustrate this I might buy
a box of just the chocolate parts of the
Oreo but I wouldn't buy a box of just
the cream part of the OREA
and that the cream does add it does add
to the Wario at texture adds flavor but
too much of it is is too much and I
think that the ratio and the original
Oreo is is perfect okay and Sam I'm like
the exact opposite like I'm always very
disappointed when on airplanes they hand
out the cookies and it's just those like
fake Oreos that are just the chocolate
you know oh yeah and I I like I can eat
processing out of a can of the spoon and
so to me the chocolate only serves as a
delivery package for the frosting hmm
and so the more frosting the better and
then and then the other thing is
honestly like it's kind of like just
because it's there I have to pee no it's
bigger like double stuff I have to get
it it's kind of like I would I would go
to when we would go to Buffalo Wild
Wings
I would always I used to always just get
blazing even though I cannot handle
blaze bling okay but I just I had to get
them because you're an overachiever no I
well hold on oh let me in your defense
let me just say that I am I can relate
to the way that you see things in terms
not just with the double stuff but like
I'm the guy that gets the new sandwich
that's available at a fast food
restaurant like if something is
advertised if something's on the end of
the scale I'm like I'm here why not go
to the end of the scale if it's a burger
and there's a there's a single and
there's a double why not get the double
I certainly get the double but I but I
take this to an extreme and I got to say
that I'm a double stuff guy when it
comes to Oreos as well but I do
recognize I feel like these are two
distinct philosophies which is which is
really interesting because I do feel
like there and I respect the the Madison
argument which is that there's this is
the original Oreo they made it that way
for a reason the people that Oreo
invented a cookie that while it didn't
wind
didn't even win the snack bracket of
much madness because we're not huge fans
of Oreos it it is a it was the overall
number one seed lots of people love it
and there's a reason that it is what it
is so but I was but I will say there's
also a reason that Double Stuf exists
and that's because the people spoke you
know I think that I feel like I'm pretty
impartial here so I because I I don't
like either but I do believe that I mean
I don't dislike them I love them in
milkshakes I've talked about this on the
munch madness I love them in all the
forms where they're added to things like
the cookies and cream of anything you
like them as an ingredient cookies and
cream
and I don't hate them I wouldn't like
gag if I ate one I mean I don't gag much
anyway but I wouldn't I wouldn't
complain if I was eating either one of
them but if I had to choose I feel like
I'm in a good impartial position I will
also say that while some people out
there may be thinking well this is just
a matter of preference
even without the staleness which was a
very compelling point earlier I will say
that we are operating on the assumption
that there is a right choice and that
they need to adopt it and I believe I
have what I believe is this is not just
an issue of preference I have what I
believe is the correct answer
okay but can I ask Madison do you ever
do that thing where you take your the
the Oreo of your preference the original
and you twist it apart and just eat the
frosting out of the middle are you how
do you feel about the frosting part at
all you you you seem to not want it
there at all have you ever twisted it
apart and then scraped off and not
consumed the frosting and just eaten the
the dark wafers no are you lying
no be truthful okay
because if if she would have told us
that then her you know so we can't even
listen to her anymore
yep she's scraping off the frosting just
eating that yeah yeah but she respects
the original Oreo okay guys I have what
I think is a good solution for this and
I do not think that it is you two
deciding on who's right or who's wrong I
have a solution to in my mind and I just
want to tell you that no matter what you
say I'm gonna say what mine is and we
may agree I think we may have the same
answer okay I think but I'm not gonna be
stealing your idea because I'm gonna
recognize saying I already have my okay
I think that this Oreo stalemate no pun
intended
don't stale is the perfect opportunity
the perfect opportunity for you guys to
connect and appreciate one another's
perspective and and I think we can do
this right now I here's what I think you
should do I think that you should not be
buying both every time you go I believe
that you should be alternating regular
double stuff regular double stuff and I
think you both should be consuming maybe
at a lower rate when it's not the one of
your preference but as an opportunity
for you to basically inhabit the
perspective of your spouse and and and I
think we could do that right now I would
like you Sam - say what you appreciate
about the original Oreo and then Madison
I would like you to tell Sam which you
appreciate about the double stuffed Oreo
and then I think you can put this into
practice every two weeks and you could
repeat these things to each other but
let's just establish the mantra and as
beautiful as this is before you do it I
will say that this is not my advice so I
think I can rescue you but you know what
I want you to I want you to go through a
red sign because I think it's a
beautiful exercise that will bring that
will bring more wholeness to your
relation I want you to build a great
beautiful I want you to build a bridge
out of Oreos of all both kinds towards
one of them so try it
so try it right now and the risk is low
because if it fails I have another
solution okay
so I think the the original oil is more
durable because you can yeah I think you
can break it up and crumble and use your
it becomes ingredient easier and just
because the the thickness of the double
stuff is a bit unwieldy
and clumsy it's I think it's just
perfect as just for dunking in the milk
and eating whole and say and can you say
in Madison I appreciate that you see
things that way in Madison I appreciate
that you keeping bread away
okay thank you great and can you say
Madison you know what I almost am
tempted to prefer Oreos your way just
because I love you so much hmm not quite
but almost not quite tempted to prefer
the original Oreo because I love you oh
that's beautiful
okay in Madison what do you have to say
to Sam I I can appreciate that the
double stuffed Oreo is is bigger and so
it it can fill you up faster and it can
satisfy you
she's digging pretty deep yeah two of
them really goes are there less than a
asleep probably yeah okay yeah and I can
appreciate that you see things that way
and I can I can I can try to to learn to
love the Double Stuf Oreos because I
love you oh wow that's that is so not
you got am it that Oreo Bridge is a
beautiful thing that's a beautiful
because it's gonna get more serious than
Oreos guys once that Oreo Bridge gets a
little milk on it though nobody it's
gonna come she it's got rebar you know
mush it down it's got Reba I'm gonna get
in the river okay when it happens this
is what you should do I think that was a
little bit of like a bless your heart
Double Stuf Oreos
oh he didn't take it oh well cause it's
bigger yeah alright okay what you guys
have to work on your inhabiting the
other person's perspective no you don't
you just have to do what I'm about to
tell okay all right
that was beautiful moment thanks for
engineering that for them I have an
engineering degree I almost respect you
more because of what you just did okay
you know when you're sculpting from a
you know if you take I'm talking like
taking a large piece of rocking and
you're chiseling away yeah to create a
wonderful David perhaps but in the shape
of an Oreo you know the principle holds
that you know you can chisel away you
can chisel away but you can't add that's
a problem once you
that's an artist who has failed you got
to start out with a new slab yep the
same with the Oreo I would submit that
you buy only the Double Stuf Oreos and
then with each one as a communal
exercise of your joint love for one
another in a jack sprat type fashion you
sit down and you both you each take one
and you both twist off and then you
Madison take a butter knife and then you
just take off as much of that frosting
as you don't want up to all of it
because I know you're hiding a secret
desire to eat a frost list Oreo and then
you give it to Sam and he slathers it on
because he would eat frosting out of the
tub
and then he puts his cap back on you put
yours on you lock eyes and you eat eat
your perfect Oreo so he's got a trip so
Sam has a triple Sammy and it's it's a
communal event there's a pacing involved
which which decreases the overall sum
for you I respect your perspective I
think that maybe there's a meld
of all these things together it's a
three week rotation not to confuse
things originalism no I want them to
respond to my advice before you start
saying whoa Mon still go to get in there
no I did your thing I don't behave your
speeches they're not mutually exclusive
what do you guys think anything worth
having is worth scraping off and sharing
with your mate Oreos are not about a
task though
well have you ever did you like fun dip
no I hate it cuz it's work it's not fun
at all to do work on my food man but I
but I think I love the idea of the
communal exercise I'm trying to give you
a compliment here I'm trying to save
your bad advice because I had a guy I
think it's a one two three rotation
about to get more frosty man are you are
you gonna pipe in ah that sounds good to
me and Plus you know variability I might
get I might get a quadruple stufs every
once in a while right but in this like
that in this scenario
Madison loses her ability to get a
regular Oreo which i think is unfair no
she doesn't
she can't yeah double stuff scraped with
a butter knife
does not equal an original Oreo that's
bullcrap man that is not original or you
got to be good at how you scratch you
know you got to get it do you think
they're Michelangelo like that's the
whole point do or do regular do double
stuff and then to do communal triple
stuff every third week yeah and your
relationship will last forever three
months from now you tell us what you've
settled off why is it okay now we've had
this question which and now it's
creating conflict between us the first
one but confused me to no end the second
one made me angry
my overall solution incorporates your
communal exercise but recognizes a
preferable that you communal exercise
and it creates so I'm saying that you do
the regular you inhabit each other's
perspective you do the double same thing
and then you do the triple this weird
thing you might as well wash you to wash
each other's feet at that time too while
you're while you're going through some
much trouble do something else make it
communal make it sweet play some weird
music pop each other's blackheads on
your nose do that too and then I think
you can have a great relationship
and maybe maybe take the week off on the
fourth week no Oreos so it's on a
monthly rotation don't want to burn out
exactly all right guys I I feel really
good about where we landed okay
good welcome good luck with that yes
thanks for calling in did she say that
was a bus to talk to I think it was a
blast
Oh a blast a bless I think she feel good
I mean I feel good about that so yeah
you know what I'm not angry
yeah I was I thought I thought your
solution was exquisite yeah I thought it
was good but it needed to only needed to
be in close around into interests you
spread it out like like more Oreo cream
on listen let's take another one let's
take another call hello welcome to ear
biscuits who do we have here I am Jordan
hello hello guys how are you good you
both seem happy but I there has to be
something seething under the surface in
your relationship that you need our help
with is that true yes ooh really
breaking us apart here okay where are
you guys first by the way we're from
Pennsylvania okay and that sounds cool
yeah it's kind of cold over here oh okay
he took that literally I was just trying
to say hey you guys seem hip but you
it's also cold this time of year and
what it what is your relationship to one
another we are we are married okay okay
how long oh newlyweds newlyweds okay
this is extra dicey I feel suddenly an
extra level of pressure I feel it was
just applied to us because we're in the
very early stages oh yeah you and make
or break territory you guys have any
kids yet to cat
to cats I'm sorry yeah okay do you guys
mate and then okay you didn't make a cat
no no yeah they did they're not you
didn't you didn't you didn't make cats
no that's a that's a different your cats
don't mate either I don't know what I'm
talking about yeah that's weird
it's all of us weird I know that it's
worth a cat yeah but you did seem to ask
that a second ago that did okay I didn't
think about it now that we got that out
of the way that you didn't actually give
birth to these cats
what is your conflict okay so there's
this thing about he thinks that it needs
to go on directly after the meat but it
obviously goes on top after all the
toppings are on it up every single time
we have taco Alvin you have tacos oh
good couple times a month at least but
the way it turns into quite the
discussion and it major assault Wow okay
taco sauce uh so okay so Matt you say
you put the meat in the tortilla then
you put the sauce Jordan you're saying
what sauce is the last step and okay and
and again yeah this is someone may say
well you could easily eat do it your own
way but that that hasn't worked for you
guys you haven't been able to walk away
and just say you know what to each their
own
yeah well like walk me through that
dynamic a little bit like why do you
both believe that we got to get to the
bottom of this and by the way we agree
there has to be an answer well the taco
sauce goes on top to hold all the
toppings well hold on no I'm not I'm not
I don't want you to get into your
argument yeah I'm just saying some some
passers-by might just say hey you know
you eat yours your way and let him eat
his this other way and then just don't
worry about it
but you guys only want to get a taco
that's the problem
yeah see they're really digging in which
I completely understand
and I think the reason that this is such
a big issue is because it's not saying
that I don't like taco sauce
I do like taco sauce you both want the
same thing to happen in your mouth right
you both want a taco with taco sauce and
toppings is that true is that is that an
accurate representation of your feelings
I would want the same things to happen
in their mouth that is why this is an
important issue because your whole 2%
right because because you don't like
tomatoes on your taco and while that may
annoy me to some degree I realized that
annoyance is just uncalled for if you
don't like tomatoes you shouldn't have
to put tomatoes on your taco but if we
both wanted tomatoes on our taco and you
thought that tomatoes should be put on
the taco in a different way we would
have to settle this or else we couldn't
eat tacos together I totally get it I
respect that - okay Jordan I cut you off
go ahead and give give me the argument
that you've been giving to Matthew sure
sorry I jumped ahead but yeah I mean the
purpose of the sauce is to hold the
cheese and the lettuce sound and to not
let it float away are you you guys at
the International Space Station yeah
okay that's in Pennsylvania they've
docked it how does your cheese float
away is it do things work differently
[Laughter]
okay all right well I mean this is a new
factor I didn't what was a big what she
means is that in it lots of times when I
have a taco and I'm I'm eating I'm also
talking I like I'm gesturing you know if
there's any even a subtle gesturing with
a taco hand you're gonna get cheese and
lettuce because they're both shredded
they're little piece yeah they want to
fly off when you're gesturing with the
taco but how much sauce does it take to
hold down those ingredients that's a lot
of sauce but no let her answer that okay
how much sauce does it take it's a lot
of thought exactly it's just like yeah
but okay so there you go so that's
that's food for thought right there
she's holding her stuff down when she
gestures you gesture with the taco
sometimes when you're like you just take
you late we're talking yeah yeah right
right okay and in Matt what do you think
about that what's your position on this
well see I like to swing my eye taco all
willy-nilly and I get the sauce
everywhere right so you're saying for
the same reason you guys have the same
reason but you've got different you've
got different applications you say and
you gesture even harder yeah it's a hard
taco gesture Matt do you have facial
hair until it's afternoon yeah
oh whoa whoa what happened were you in
an accident he's in a shaving accident
I ran face-first into some Clippers oh
well the reason I ask that is because I
don't know what your position is yet
link but my position is definitely sauce
on the meat
because if sauce is on the outer layer
as a mustache - man anything that leads
with sauce first creates a problem
whereas cheese and lettuce bounce off of
my moustache and usually be their back
into the taco or into my mouth or on the
floor yeah I've seen you two talk see if
something is sauce forward it's like
drinking sauce out of a cup at that
point I've just got sauce all over my
moustache which is not that big of a
problem but if I have to make the choice
and I often do I will put taco sauce on
the meat because I want the wet
ingredients the wet meat and the sauce
to be in one place and then I want the
dry ingredients to be on top of that
math yes well my point is the sour cream
holds everything together
ooh see we're trying it we're trying to
give them arguments left and right and
they're not they're not using sour cream
is a much better binding agent than
sauce that was another thing I didn't
you know but but by your argument you
would put meat sauce sour cream and then
the other toppings Rhett but but Matthew
you're not saying that are you are you
saying you're saying you put sour cream
on the very top in the same place that
Jordan puts
oh no no it goes the taco meat sauce and
then the sour cream you bet everything
okay okay you fed it into the sour cream
okay so man that is see here's the thing
that I hate about tacos if they're
ripping couples apart I mean and I also
hate tacos because the the whole way
that you make a taco renders it
impossible for a person of an average to
even above average size mouth to get a
bite of everything at once I'm talking
about a hard taco here a crunchy taco if
you bite you bite really high you're not
gonna get meat and if you bite too low
you know you got a bite high and you're
getting toppings and you know again meat
and then that's not a good bite that's a
bad bite and then your your you have to
immediately take a second bites like
chop chop in order to get the meat and
that's it it just annoys me so much that
I want to walk away from tacos
altogether the problem is they taste so
good when you finally get everything in
your mouth but I don't like having to
take two bites in order to make one good
bite and that's why I hate tacos and I
also hate them because they're ripping
families apart but that's I mean that
seems different
tacos are that from the ground up there
a problem okay there a problem
food point taken as a man with a below
average sized mouth and a mustache I if
anybody agrees with you about the
trouble that tacos bring the world I'm
there with you but I'm not gonna
complain about two bikes I love to to
bites are better than one and so and
also regardless of the structure of the
taco two bites are not better than one
because once you take a bite you want to
chew and enjoy you don't want to
immediately have to shove a second you
right right on top you got to take a
stand by bite you take a bite at the top
and then you take a bite you hold it
take a bite of the bottom you get it all
in your mouth and you mix it together
and you have a taco surprise you do that
yeah that's my technique but you know
what I'm sorry that you have to do that
and and I and I accept your apology
even given the fact that I've got to
take two bites I still think that the
sounder argument here is Matt because I
feel like from as someone who almost
became a structural engineer and then
became a civil engineer and then stop
doing that shortly after to become an
Internet comedian I realized I have very
little very little qualification here
but that one structural engineering
class but we did not discuss tacos I can
say that from an engineering perspective
matt is right okay well well on that
point Jordan what what do you do what's
your area of expertise what do I do for
a living yeah I'm a veterinary
technician I don't know how that's gonna
help you here well that's you know
that's honest Matthew what about you
what's your area of expertise I am a
wastewater operator I just let the water
flow so it doesn't help me either but
you are a man familiar with messes what
they both are well do I true that's
right both working in in crap yeah but
but Matt is working exclusively in crap
you know what I'm saying
so I so I think they I think he is the
authority here okay and as it as a
former engineer who got close to dealing
with such subjects I gotta say that I
think he's got a sound argument because
again if you were actually at the
International Space Station and Jordans
cheese and lettuce was floating away
even still I think that if you were to
stuff that into a bed of sour cream even
an astronaut could enjoy it and so to me
I feel like this is a pretty pretty
case-closed situation and because um a
mess with sauce is a much worse mess
than a mess with cheese and lettuce
I too am in agreement with Matthew oh
wow okay
Jordan but but like you don't be so
tempted as to then put the sauce in the
meat it still needs to be a separate
experience that you add at your own
leisure after the meetings been fully
prepared and put in a bowl put it on the
meat not into me not in the meat don't
go that far
okay Jordan what do you think about this
are you willing to change the way you
make a taco no why did you call yeah we
got to start the we got to start these
overs like no matter what we say do you
agree
we got to do that up front we can't do
it after we say who we disagree with
we're learning something I mean I'm
really heartbroken but if that's the
right way that's that's what I have to
do from now on you'll have less sauce on
your face you'll be you'll be and then
if if the lettuce of cheese falls on the
floor I bet you that Matthew is willing
to make a commitment to pick it up for
you 30% of the time he can eat it off
the ground
Matthew you are you are you willing to
take one for the team in terms of
cleanup because the cleanup is you have
argued is is much more manageable and
your specialty oh yeah I do
enough cleanup I think we're gonna have
to ever but my method yeah I'm saying
she switches to your method and in
exchange the the mess that she makes
which is less you're willing to help
with it oh yeah all right or you can
give it to your kids Jordan does that
make you feel better about switching up
yeah that's that's a fair trade but what
we need to do is we need to come
together we need to build a different
taco we need to build a taco that is a
one bite taco I think you're talking
about a smaller taco like a street taco
cuz a street taco does not have the
problem that you're describing and I
think it's the reason they were invented
and a soft taco you can start to roll
over like a burrito
yeah and that starts to close the end
though because then you've made a
burrito and then the taco has died and
we don't want that okay guys you know
you're early into this marriage but I
think we have I think we've helped a
little bit and no art no hard feelings
Jordan does sometimes sometimes there's
a solution to a problem and
you just happen to be on the wrong end
of it tonight and you know what it's a
really good sign in a marriage when you
have to call two idiots on the Internet
in order to settle stuff so I think you
got a great relationship ahead of you
thank you so much guys yeah thanks for
calling good luck with that
thank you can we have another caller I
just love this yes let's have let's have
one more
oh hello welcome to ear biscuits who do
we have here and where are you calling
from
hi Lydia and Lenny sale you say you
sound like a we're good like a duo of
some kind we are married so how about I
say you sound like a musical duo and you
okay and what do you call yourselves
Lydia Lenny give us some bars give us a
scale okay and I was not okay she was
not a player
like a human metronome that was actually
pretty impressive dude what's your
problem what's your problem
well among many okay we have the deal
Breton Lake back all you rhettandlink
yeah sure okay great I'm sure Lenny
I like the temperature okay oh we get it
yeah this is the temperature I like the
house between a nice 50 and 60 degrees
now let me tell you I don't it's not
like the low fifties you know I'm not
like trying to you know keep ice cream
and just in the living room but I like
it to be you know 58 62 degrees and my
wife doesn't yeah I am naturally a cold
person so I like the house I like the
five seventy and I think that like
especially when company comes over we
should keep the house that like seventy
maybe even like seventy five on the cold
days it's still spring here and I know
like it's nobility
so yeah Wow that's it okay
well let this just initial observation
again each give me one number I just
want to I don't want to work with these
ranges in order to simplify before we
get into it can you Lenny give me your
one number because first of all you said
fifty to sixty and then you said 58 60 -
oh that's what's your number yeah what
would it be what would the temperature
be if you want if he had to select a
temperature for all the time inside all
the time it would probably just be an
even 60 okay and Lydia um 71 so anyone
okay now just initial observations and
how cold is it outside him I'm sorry to
cut you off right I just need to it was
58 degrees today
58 okay yeah it's actually warmer in
Idaho that I thought okay so now just in
terms of modern western society lynnie
you are clearly the outlier here just
from the just from the gig okay okay
no do you recognize that well I guess
you know I I did not know well that's
just the way I guess you know what it's
just the way I was raised so it gets my
family they are the outliers as well
okay where'd you grow up well I mean I
grew up in Nevada which is not I mean
it's north I will grew up in
northeastern Nevada which is whether
it's similar to Boise yeah okay but
that's that's mostly I think that's
where so I guess where this comes from
is my mom always had the the adage that
if you're cold put clothes on and so she
always gets the house around 60 degrees
it's me they got it's kind of like my
sculpture analogy you can put more
clothes on but at a certain point
there's nothing else to take off and if
you bring our guests well that can get
awkward or interesting
well okay clear that that's clearly
right but sixty degrees inside your put
your putting on quite a bit of clothing
now and are you saying that when it gets
hot are you saying that when it's really
hot outside your mom would have the AC
on all the way down to 60 mm-hmm I would
say that she probably yeah I think so
okay so here was the house I think the
house was always like if she had her way
was an always an even 60 or around there
so this is not a this is not an
energy-saving or clearly not nothing's
right because I think that's Lydia he he
wants to turn the AC on I don't know how
hot it gets in Boise but in the heat in
the heat of the summer
I mean he's blad he's going to blast the
AC yeah yeah this is not a money issue
okay right I would say this more like I
just 60 degrees to me feels like I could
go outside like the house when it's
really hot out like boy she gets out boy
I mean it's gotten up to 90 degrees
before so 60 degrees sounds pretty nice
then and then just in the winter when
you know Koster I guess if you they feel
higher it yeah I feel like this is
probably not right but I feel like it's
more expensive to keep your house warm
than it is to be cold but it's probably
not right well
oh okay what link is getting I'm
thinking the same thing if this were a
cost savings thing so if you were like
when it gets cold during the winter I
don't want it to be any warmer than 60
degrees because it's cold outside and
we're come in we've got clothes on
already for going outside so we come
inside so you would have a point if then
the opposite of the argument was also
true the opposite situation we're like
during the summer I want it to be warmer
because it's already warm outside right
now if that was your position I would
say I'm a sympathizer to that position
for a number of reasons the first reason
being energy savings and I think that is
the responsible thing the visit
responsible position to take and also
linked as I've been telling you I've
been started to read about this wim HOF
guy the Iceman thing yeah and he he
basically his philosophy is that we've
pampered ourselves into this perfect
acceptable temperature range which is
contrary to our entire history as a
species and we've actually made
ourselves a weaker we were designed to
be able to be in very cold environments
and in very hot environments and be able
to regulate our body temperature so I'm
actually moving towards a place or I
want there to be a larger temperature
fluctuation in my own home during the
different seasons even though I live in
Southern California there's not much to
deal with but that's not what you're
saying well is Lenny are you trying to
strengthen the ruddiness of yourself and
Lydia can i okay can i peek in your for
a second yeah I think it's important to
know that we lived in a house during the
dead of winter without any heating at
all like it just wasn't an option so I
feel like we have already done our duty
to prepare ourself for that and okay now
that we have a house with me I think
that we should allow ourselves to use it
and renown them yeah you got it for that
one no no no I I think that is a valid
argument but I think I guess what I'm
thinking now actually even hearing about
this temperature flux thing that that
we're just talking about I think I'm
more in line with that because I think
originally why I wanted to keep it
because we moved into this home we're
actually just recently moved into it
about I think you've been living here
about four five four months okay
so I think we haven't actually
experienced another season besides
winter and spring or we haven't
experienced the higher side and so I
think I would be willing to try out
keeping the temperature higher because I
think that's originally what I was
thinking was to save money and I guess I
haven't really I didn't really have a
thought about what it would be like in a
summer even though I don't like to be
hot very much cool okay well okay this
is interesting because you just you
basically said that
you're willing to do this more natural
temperature fluctuation experiment for
whatever reason cost savings
ruddiness as link pointed out as long as
he stays cold but can't take the heat
and then now you feel like Lydia feels
now when she's cold
no and I and I understand that I I think
all that coming while I was saying it so
but I would be willing to give up that
that comfort that I'm used to or that I
want to try out the experiment yeah I
mean listen here's the here's the
difficult thing as I music basically he
just said he's doubling down on his
position now and then he's willing to
suffer in the summer if it does get hot
but the problem is is that Lydia may not
want to be too cold or too hot and and
that would put her in the majority
position so what I'm saying is I feel
like I've just learned about something
with this whole wim HOF thing that is
clouding my perspective and I'm trying
to move to a place where I'm more
willing to tolerate temperature
fluctuation but if you live with someone
the only way to apply that that happen
to apply that is to get my wife and my
kids to be on the same page and that's
probably a lot to ask and so I'm
probably not gonna be able to do in my
house because if I tell my wife hey I
wanted to be really cold and winter and
really hot in the summer I am doing it
for readiness then she's gonna be like
well get your uh detail out of here
because I went to be 70 degrees at all
times and that's gonna be a very
difficult argument to win so it really
feels like the answer here is compromise
well and we're talking about sixty five
and a half degrees in the winter and I
would say setting some having a
negotiation between the two of you you
don't have to do it right now
but agree on your target temperature for
each of the season
and in just be like hey this is this is
where we're gonna be this is where we
can both be comfortable but still
develop a little bit of you know reading
environmental consciousness and
readiness
yeah sixty-five degrees in the in the in
the winter
so hey in the summer good you might go I
mean you might go 74 in the summer not
76 but I like that and when people come
over
lynnie let her do what she wants because
she's got more sense than you right
exactly when it comes yep yep she she's
she's enduring I mean you blaming it on
your momma so we can just put it on her
she's enduring what you're the problems
your mama created and you can just just
cut her some slack
cuz she let her that's her thing man
when when when people come over she
knows how to do it you-you'd alright you
know your dysfunctional and I you know
what I am I am I am too in a different
way
well guys I hope we've we've helped you
a little bit alright guys good luck with
that
thank you okay guys there you have it we
had a lot of fun meddled in people's
lives you know but they asked for it I
feel like at the end of the day we did
more good than harm you never know if
there was a component of harm I just you
know we can't quantify it I do think
there's a chance that that one couple is
gonna cut themselves during that Oreo
ceremony that you suggested but you know
they can report back and let us know you
make it sound like a satanic ritual but
you know what we're gonna have to do
this again of course using hashtag ear
biscuits on all the social media outlets
that you know of please let us know what
you thought about this calling episode
we're continuing to experiment with what
we do on this show and if you want to be
able to talk to us or have us respond to
one of your questions complaints or
concerns look at the props that we post
on social media wherever social media
prompts are found yeah you know the
places all right we'll speak
got you next week until then good luck
with that
[Music]